a bit of breaking news to bring you in
with context of the Nottingham attacks
we're hearing from police said that a
man has been charged with three counts
of murder and three counts of attempted
murder uh within that context of those
attacks that of course following the
attacks in Nottingham uh that took place
on the 13th of June we know the
suspect's name valdo kalakane 31 no
fixed Abode charged with those three
counts of murder he will appear at
Nottingham magistrates court on Saturday
this Saturday the 17th of June the
statement goes on to read that of course
those charges relate to the students
Barnaby Philip John Weber and Grace
Sashi O'Malley Kumar both of them aged
19 fatally stabbed in ilkeston Road just
after 4 a.m and as of course we have
been reporting Ian Robert Coates also 65
the school caretaker who was later found
fatally stabbed in magadella Road the
further three charges of attempted
murder relate to three members of the
public who were struck by a van Chief
Constable Kate mainel of Nottinghamshire
police has said these charges are a
significant development and a rise as a
result of our thorough investigation
into these horrific incidents that
occurred in our city she has asked the
people has asked people to respect the
family's wishes for privacy at this
difficult time and to be allowing them
to grieve we have of course seen through
the course of the Day flowers being laid
at that site in Nottingham in fact the
pictures that you're seeing now uh mint
this the vigil now yesterday and of
course this has been a a two-day events
of minutes at silence and of course the
vigils in memory of those three people
killed in that attack the police
Constable going on to say we're keenly
aware of the deep emotion being felt
surrounding these tragic events and the
high level of Interest not only in
Nottingham and Nottinghamshire but also
across the whole country she warns
though uh that posting prejudicial
information online about an active case
could amount to contempt of a court and
in the most serious cases have the
potential to call the cause the collapse
of a trial of course this uh relating to
the fact that there was a scramble to
try and name uh the suspect uh he has
now publicly been named as valdo
kalakarni 31 years old no fixed address
so as we were saying uh just then the
breaking news that we are hearing that
the suspect in the Nottingham attacks
valdo calocan it has been charged with
three counts of murder and three counts
of attempted murder for that attack
that took place on Saturday we'll just
read you again a little bit of the
statement that we have had from the
police she does say that these charges
are a significant development and of
course they are arising as a result of
the thorough investigation into those
horrific in incidents it has only been a
matter of days since that attack and
already we have the name of the suspect
and of course more information being
released about the people who were
involved in that attack two 19 year old
students at Nottingham University and a
school caretaker 65 years of age known
as a well-loved school caretaker who was
also killed in that attacker the
attempted murder those three counts of
attempted murder will relate of course
to those who were struck by a van
earlier in the day uh that so that's
there's a three that because as we're
saying there valdo carlokani charged
with those three counts of murder but
also three counts of attempted murder so
it is now clear that it was him who was
behind all of those attacks that they
can now be linked to for certain uh the
three counts of murder and of course
those three counts of attempted murder
those events uh unfolded on this on the
13th of July we can go directly to Lisa
Dowd Lisa you're in Nottingham now
thanks very much for for scrambling to
join us as we get that news so there we
have it uh valdo colacani now charged
with those three counts of murder and
attempted murder
yes and the 31 year old will be
appearing before a court here in
Nottingham Nottingham magistrates court
in the morning he has been charged with
three counts of murder and three counts
of attempted murder and we know that
valdo kalikarni who is 31 years old is
of no fixed address
and we know that he is accused of the
murder of three people in this city on
Tuesday they are Barnaby Weber Grace
O'Malley Kumar and Ian Coates two
students and a school caretaker who were
stabbed to death in this city on that
morning and the attempted murder charges
relate to three other people who were
run down run over in the city in a
different location to those people they
are currently recovering from the injury
to are in a stable condition in hospital
and thankfully one has been discharged
from hospital and now we've also got a
statement from the chief Constable Kate
mainel from Nottinghamshire police she
says these charges are a significant
development and a riser results of our
thorough investigation into these
horrific incidents that occurred in our
city our thoughts remain with the
families and friends of all those
affected by these attacks and we
continue to provide support and
reassurance we would also ask people to
respect the family's wishes for privacy
at this difficult time to allow them to
breathe this has been an incredibly sad
time for our city and county and We
Stand United with our communities as we
come to terms with the effects of what
has happened we are keenly aware of the
deep emotion being felt surrounding
these tragic events and the high level
of Interest not only in Nottingham and
Nottinghamshire but also across the
whole country and we know that the
families of those victims have found
great comfort in the city in this city
at lunch time today actually Barnaby
Weber's family took some time to go to
the spot on ilkeston road where he lost
his life a police closed the road off
there and the family stood round for 10
minutes or so and they were at points
crying at points laughing they stood in
a circle looking after each other
hugging each other remembering Barnaby
and they laid single flowers onto the
roadside as people stood and watched in
silence and then they went to have a
look at some of the flowers that have
been left on on railings in tribute to
both Barnaby and Grace who who simply
lost their lives while walking home from
a night out and of course as well here
in the City Center yesterday there's a
huge vigil held for all of those victims
and including Ian Coates who was a
school caretaker who was so fondly
Remembered in this city for his love of
fishing and trying to get students into
fishing pushing a course actually hoping
that he could get people from or young
people from troubled backgrounds to to
take on that sport all of them linked by
sport actually
Barnaby and Grace and both talented
cricketers Grace a talented hockey
player and Ian Coates a big football fan
a big Forest fan that we heard all about
during the Vigilant Market Square
yesterday and the flowers in the city
center continue to grow as people come
and think and reflect about what
happened and it's had reverberations far
beyond this city and these deaths
because we've seen actually at the day
one of the ashes and the cricketers
there both England and Australia wearing
armbands in memory of those three
victims having a moment's silence and
coming together to think and reflect
about something bigger than sport about
what has been lost and as the news of
this these charges come in we expect to
see a 31 year old man appearing in court
here in Nottingham in the morning
sir thank you very much Lisa down there
in Nottingham we will of course come
back to Nottingham when we have more for
you